puisque quelqu'un en vie de sorte que
les retoucher ou chanter là dessus je
n'avais pas prévu qu'on tombe amoureux
je veux pas tomber mes comptes relève
athée je veux pouvoir de la tristesse
dans les yeux
comment réduire la vitesse d aceh si
parfois du cool et je ferai tout ce que
je veux pour détruire ces questions et
je ferai au mieux s'il le monde
s'écroule on fera des objets on
regardera la foule en s'embrassant peut
vous êtes formidables un jour je prends
un train paris lyon part dieu est face à
moi elle est assise un charmant garçon
presque de mon agence ans cinq six ans
de moins on discute pendant le voyage
pas trop il est dans son son qu'on
appelle ça son ordinateur le voyage se
passe bien et avant de partir il fait
glisser sa carte comme ça sur la
tablette est vendue en voilà si un jour
vous avez besoin de moi appelez moi
voilà donc je trouve ça charmant j'ai
pas mes lunettes donc je récupère la
carte je prends mes lunettes et je
regarde y avait créé un chirurgien
esthétique
je sais pas comment il faut le prendre
vous êtes formidables
vous pouvez
lui
ok dites moi que vous êtes un vrai mec
sans dire que vous êtes un vrai mec ce
qu'avance
beaucoup les
amener des vrais jeunes
[Musique]
l'homme qui préside à serrer la
et
[Musique]